you look so beautiful you you look
beautiful we are such huge fans of yours
at our house I mean me and my two
daughters Olive and Frankie first of all
we love Cobra Kai obviously but uh which
is
the fact you are so good in that show
um and I just thought like what that
show put out there was like awesome for
girls and boys like men and women you
know it's nice to see
like your character and that show is so
damn capable
yeah I appreciated that quality as well
because our showrunners have daughters
and they actually they were supposed to
do yoga the girls were supposed to do
yoga at their school and the boys were
getting separated into karate and the
girls fought for karate after Cobra Kai
and I was like oh it actually has an
impact like that's insane I love yoga
but it's like I do too we should all be
doing you know whatever lens to our
capacities is it I have a picture of you
with Catherine Heigl that is the cutest
thing
um ever look how tiny you are oh my gosh
do you remember this moment yes and what
was going on in this moment that was the
after party of the premiere of 27
Dresses where I played the younger
version of her which is also another
loved movie God do I need that on a
Sunday like it just brightens my spirits
I love that movie yeah it's it's so
funny I forget that I was even a part of
it because I'm like a blip in the very
first scene but
that was like one of my first movies
that I did and you worked with Kate
Hudson too did you enjoy that I did yeah
I was just growing up in New York I was
just playing a younger version of every
blonde while going to school like if
there was a blonde woman I would play
her younger version and I didn't realize
until now how cool that was like that is
so cool all those awesome blondes I love
it and then we have the connection of
Adam Sandler because you were in Hubie
Halloween which fun fact I actually flew
up there we were trying to I basically I
do audition for this role so I asked
Adam if I could interview him and he
said yeah so I flew up to uh huby the
set of Hubie Halloween and we went in
Salem Massachusetts yes exactly so I was
I was technically on the set but I
didn't get the pleasure of seeing you I
love that movie yeah it's so funny I
feel like you guys are both down for
anything like you're both such humble
Souls who like do so much and are just
so versatile well it's insane like the
fact that you're hosting the show I love
this show you do yes
[Applause]
at me
to my girls I mean you have such a large
following of people who like look up to
you and like how cool like that might I
can't wait to play that over and over
and over again for my daughters they
will think that's so cool because they
think you're so cool
um all right you are coming out in
school Spirits
um it's Paramount plus it looks so good
so juicy producers of um Pretty Little
Liars and it just looks so juicy and
good
and I will you explain it because I I
could do it for you but then that would
be weird it's your show yeah you know
um this girl Maddie nears she's uh just
finds out in the very first scene that
she's missing and she's sort of in this
weird in between place trying to figure
out what happened to her and how she
disappeared that's right High School
purgatory exactly setting classic
setting the scene and it is a very like
who done it rolling out mystery that's
what I mean about that juicy delicious
like that genre just keeps you on the
hook like what's gonna happen what's
going to be revealed you know oh we have
a clip Oh yay we're gonna take a look at
a clip
you've died at the homecoming game yeah
and my family still shows up for me
every year so that's a show up for that
wait you're coming to the game right
yeah but I'm just going to watch the
cheerleaders I think you mean one
cheerleader in particular
[Applause]
all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break but when we come back I
want to like pick Peyton's mind a beauty
product that Peyton can't live without a
few suggestions don't go away
foreign
[Music]